je voudrait interroger le gouvernement
qui nous apporte quelques précisions
suite aux déclarations du chef de l'état
hier soir sur la crise sanitaire le chef
de l'état a indiqué que la poursuite de
la délivrance du pass and it erp serait
conditionnée pour les personnes de plus
de 65 ans à l'administration d'une dose
de rappel d'ailleurs il me semble que
c'est la première fois qu'une borne
d'âge est posée est ce que première
question cette mesure va être étendu à
l'ensemble de la population éligible au
vaccin
deuxième question si le pass sanitaires
et comme cela semble l'outil qui permet
de maintenir une protection collective
élevé par la vaccination dans votre
stratégie alors à quelles conditions
estimez vous que le pass sanitaires
pourraient être levés je remercie pour
vous répondre la parole un comité
solidarité ne le font pas monsieur v en
messieurs mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur
pourquoi cela
vous n'étiez pas la consommation qui
chipe et allons-y vous étiez peut-être
pas là mais j'étais là hier soir à 11
heures du soir j'étais là avant-hier
aussi au sénat peut-être que certains
d'entre vous n'étaient pas là donc ils
ne m'ont pas aperçu rassurez vous je
suis au sénat toutes les semaines et un
certain nombre d'heures on peut regarder
si vous voulez mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur bernard
jomier vous posez vous poser une
question sur l'extension du pass à
lithaire d'abord vous dire qu'il ya de
cohérence au moins à ce que on propose
cette vaccination en priorité aux 65 ans
et plus et désormais bientôt aux 50 ans
et plus vous le savez pas ce que vous
êtes médecin mais le système immunitaire
est plus fragile quand on prend un peu
de l'âge et donc le système immunitaire
a besoin d'avoir des rappels de
vaccination c'est le cas pour le coc
vide c'est le cas pour d'autres virus
qu'on connaît bien pour pouvoir
réactiver le système immunitaire pour
vérifier qu'on est bien le même niveau
de protection la même capacité à
synthétiser des anticorps le moment où
on est confrontés à un virus pourquoi la
logique tu passe d'abord nous avons
laissé du temps aux personnes âgées de
65 ans et plus pour se faire vacciner
les trois quarts d'entre elles
d'ailleurs qu'ils étaient éligibles sont
hors saison d'ores et déjà reçu une dose
de rappel qui est un très bon chiffre
mais ça veut dire qu'il en reste encore
et surtout la logique du pass le passé à
lithaire c'est quoi c'est que lorsque
vous rentrez dans un lieu public avec du
monde notamment un lieu fermé vous avez
un moindre risque d'être contaminé
vous-même et de contaminer les autres
donc si on considère qu'au bout d'un
moment la protection conférée par le
vaccin est moins importante il est
logique du coup de restreindre l'accès
au pacini terre donc c'est pourquoi le
président la république a lancé cet
appel de la même manière on est en train
de descendre progressivement en âge sur
le rappel de la vaccination à mesure
d'ailleurs qu'on avait commencé la
vaccination souvenez-vous chez les
personnes les plus âgées et ensuite par
tranche d'âge nous avons des retours sur
la population âgée de 65 ans et plus
nous avons des retours sur la population
de 50 ans et plus les populations plus
jeunes ont été vaccinées plus tard dans
notre pays et ailleurs dans le monde
donc nous n'avons pas encore le retour
sur l'évolution de l'humanité est ce que
les scientifiques nous disent c'est que
peut-être dans quelques mois nous
verrons qu'il sera nécessaire de
proposer un rappel de vaccination plus
large en tous les cas nous agissons en
fonction des données scientifiques pour
protéger les français quant à la
question de savoir à quand le la
suppression du pass sanitaires
aujourd'hui nous faisons face à une
recrudescence de l'épidémie s'est
certainement pas le moment de se poser
la question
jugée au mieux
monsieur le ministre je comprends bien
donc nous allons vers des rappels pour
l'ensemble de la population et que la
délivrance du pass and i ter sera
conditionnée à ses rappels donc vous
tracer une perspective où à l'horizon
d'un an deux ans trois ans le pass
sanitaires se poursuivra peut-être alors
moi je voudrais vous dire que nous
portons l'idée que la vie en société
impose des obligations et vous le savez
en l'occurrence la vaccination mais nous
avons le sentiment qu'avec cet outil du
pass sanitaires vous êtes en train de
changer paradigme sur la question du
contrôle car de fait vous utilisez un
outil que vous étendez sans qu'on n'en
perçoivent bien les limites et vous
étendez le champ des contrôles
systématiques en lieu et place des
contrôles aléatoires et a posteriori qui
dans une société démocratique et de
liberté sont les plus répandus et c'est
là que se situe une interrogation
profonde pour les parlementaires que
nous sommes attachés aux libertés
publiques et avec regret je constate
d'ailleurs que le conseil
constitutionnel ne nous apporte pas d'
analyse qui soit très contributif sur ce
point
[Applaudissements]
les collègues andré guiol pour le gros
du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame la secrétaire d'état chargé de la
biodiversité
bérengère à bas madame la ministre nous
ne savons plus à quel saint se vouer en
effet cette année la production de miel
en france s'avère deux fois inférieur